as a mother of three
let me tell you why I absolutely love this parallel toy
firstly look at the terrain this thing covers grass
dirt sand gravel
we tested it on everything and it did not struggle
this is true four wheel drive
this is actually remote controls
the parent have full control of a baby
it even has a Bluetooth radio
so you can play your own music or the music that comes of it
and my son like that part
it actually has spring suspension so no harsh bumps
it has this cute little storage area
that my son likes to bring his snacks and teddy bears in
the bar lights actually do light up
and they're really bright LED lights
and so does the head lamps in the front
so you can definitely use this in the evenings
this Jeep had no problem in all the terrains on our farm
my other children also had fun
they were 4 and 7 and they also love to drive it
it can be driven by the steering wheel as well
it also had great suspension and had no issues going over these poles right here
my son absolutely loved it
and your kids are gonna love it too